but we can get some more analysis of the
situation on the ground in Ukraine with
me again in the studio as the military
expert and Veteran British army tank
commander Justin Crump he's also chief
executive of civil line uh Justin always
good to have you back in here with us we
were watching Alex Crawford's report
there from severo uh Danielle's Russian
forces still pushing into it is it just
a matter of time really before they've
taken over the donbass there's still
quite a few variables on that I think
and we've seen Russia go from this plan
of obviously taking large sways of
Countryside quickly to try and take more
moderate sways of the donbassador now
really focusing very much on this
Eastern end of the donbass and luhansk
oblast in particular and severe.nets
because we've seen there so I wouldn't
call this a Russian breakthrough that
we've seen so far but it's certainly
some of the biggest advances they've
achieved in the last couple of months
still measured in maybe a mile or two a
day on average so pretty limited but the
focus on severo Donetsk
um wrong side of the river for Ukraine
the river is a really important
Battlefield feature makes it harder to
defend a really important area actually
is to the West on The High Ground here
for now and of course Ukraine just
trying to keep supplies open from the
other cities to the west but coming
under pressure all around this area so
it's slow and steady for Russia but they
are grinding forwards I wouldn't again
call it a breakthrough but they are
grinding forwards and we're in a race to
see which side can sustain that longer
and how how much price really Ukraine
can make Russia pay for every meeting
well president zielinski saying that
even if he does get it and it's great
swathes of it are going to be
uninhabitable yes and I think you've
seen the destruction there in severeign
population have left this area largely
evacuated by Ukraine two months ago when
it became clear it would be the focus of
the Russian advance but many people just
have nowhere else to go as we saw there
so I mean a huge tragedy unfolding for
them and it will get worse as we move
towards slovian's Kramer talks in due
course now let's talk about weapons
because there are reports that the U.S
is going to be sending some long-range
weapons to Ukraine now there's long
range weapons and there's long range
weapons there are yeah and so I think we
have a picture coming up of one of the
systems that's being talked about from
the U.S side so this is the mlrs this is
it in in Dutch service it's a multiple
rocket launch system the UK uses these
as well and these might be systems that
are sent to Ukraine from the UK that Liz
trust was just discussing there
um it can be fitted though with
different types of rockets and I think
that's where the confusion's lying about
is it a 300 kilometer system or is it a
70 kilometer system and I think what
Ukraine really needs is the 70 kilometer
system that allows it which is what you
see here that allows it to strike
Russian supplies a little bit further
away than it can at the moment it's much
more effective for them I think the very
long range missile Ukraine won't be
given because that is probably quite
provocative towards Russia I think
that's on that Unwritten line that we're
concerned about Crossing in terms of how
much support it would be seen as too
much by Russia and prompt them to react
further so for now it's really focused
on this area I think they want that sort
of artillery it's an artillery War
really to grind forward this way and
that's why Ukraine's focused on these
systems and we're focused on sending
them to them okay all right Justin thank